wow we have been talking about it for
weeks now the Oakland A's moving to Las
Vegas but today Bally's who announced
that binding agreement with the A's to
take over the site of the Tropicana and
they kind of backpedaled a little bit
eight news now investigator Kyle Payne
joining us in studio to explain Kyle
Denise you got it yesterday Bally's in
the A's announced a binding agreement
and we reported that if it goes forward
the trop will very likely be demolished
but today Bally's came out with a
two-page q a saying plans are only quote
in the very preliminary stages and not
finalized for a ballpark
I think that there's a greater
likelihood that it happens than not
Clark County Commissioner Jim Gibson in
an interview you'll only see on 8 news
now seems to know about as much today as
he did a few weeks ago when we
interviewed him then would you say
economically financially this is a done
deal no that was when the Oakland A's
said they were tying up land on the
other side of the strip before the
latest news that they might tear down
and redevelop the Tropicana which is
owned by Bally's and today Bally sent
out this two pages of q a which was
short on specifics and heavy on if
what's going on
well I don't know the answer to that
what Gibson does know is what we've been
hearing for weeks that the legislature
needs to present a bill with specifics
on how all this will work that bill
might materialize this week and when it
does Gibson says the commission will
evaluate crunch the numbers and see how
the pieces all fit together there's no
answers
well I I won't quarrel with you another
person he won't quarrel with is this
Clark County resident who spoke at
today's council meeting is this going to
be a burden on the uh the community and
the taxpayers who pointed out the A's
who say they're expecting some 30 000
fans a game and 2.5 million people a
year are drawing historically low number
of fans some of that might be because
they're leaving but it also might be
because they have baseball's worst
record 9 and 34. if the ownership is
going to spend a billion plus dollars to
come here they understand that they have
to have a team that is competitive to
succeed here
in our interview Gibson also said this
deal with the A's quote cannot be a rope
around our throats he also told me
whatever ends up at the Tropicana site
needs to be a functioning contributing
part of that area of the strip but in
the end he said let's get about the
business of funding and building a
stadium Denise